bonjour je m'appelle Johanna je suis de
Saint-André je me suis installée en
auto-entrepreneur dans le domaine du
bien-être depuis le 3 juin 2013 je
propose donc des massages de bien-être
comme la réflexologie plantaire le
massage à l'huile le massage d'oreilles
que les gens aiment beaucoup parce que
c'est proposé dans pas beaucoup
d'endroits et le massage à ma assis en
soin énergétique je propose le soin
reiky et le soin allégorie et je propose
aussi de l'hypnose Ericsonienne en
séance individuel et en atelier
autoohypnose mon projet serait de
m'installer dans un plus grand local
pour pouvoir faire travailler pour
pouvoir travailler avec d'autres
personnes dans le domaine du bien-être
toujours comme par exemple un coach
sportif euh une ongle une protésiste
onulaire enfin bon tout ce qui touche au
bien-être ma différence ce son c'est
peut-être mes prix qui sont qui font
partie des plus bas du marché pour qu'un
plus large public puisse accéder à ce
genre de service qui reste quand même
luxueux à mes
yeux je es venu donc participer à ce
challenge pour apporter une nouvelle
réponse donc au réunionnés sur une
pathologie que beaucoup connaissent sans
forcément pouvoir l'identifier il s'agit
des traitements de remonté par Cap ité
cette humidification à la base des murs
qui nous embête qui fait que sans arrêt
nous sommes obligés de repeindre de
reprendre donc nos habitats mais
aujourd'hui on a surtout une réponse qui
va être à la fois économique et une
réponse qui va être écologique
économique tout simplement parce que ce
procédé géomagnétique des traitements de
remontée par capillarité va être un
procédé qui est autonome pas de pile pas
de batterie pas d'énergie consommée donc
pas de pollution de notre environnement
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que c'est un
des rares procédés qui vous a apporte
une garantie bien sûr décennale mais qui
va également vous apporter une garantie
de résultat si vous n'arrivez pas à
traiter ou si nous n'arrivons pas à le
traiter ensemble nous vous remboursons
votre investissement moins une petite
vêusteté comme la loi nous y autorise
voilà donc 10% par an ce n'est rien ce
n'est rien de prendre donc cette
responsabilité de se dire je peux
traiter ma
maison bonjour Oliv Olivier Vitri 32 ans
j'ai créé une activité de service à la
personne on intervient au domicile des
particuliers soit pour des services à la
famille comme soutien scolaire garde
d'enfant des services pour le confort
jardinage ménage aide àassage aide
ménagère et également l'aide aux
personnes aggé et dépendante donc j'ai
créé l'activité en fin 2012 on va je
vais avoir bientôt 2 ans d'activité et
j'ai actuellement 14 salariés dans mon
agence plus la création de mon propre
emploi donc deux emplois d'avenir à
temps plein euh depuis l'ouverture de
l'agence donc la première année a été un
petit peu compliquée avec la le parcours
du combattant que c'est pour créer son
entreprise euh mais avec les aides que
j'ai pu avoir dans le cadre de la
création d'entreprise que ce soit avec
réunion entreprend la Chambre de
commerce ou tous les structures qui
existent c'est vrai que c'est aussi un
bonheur de pouvoir créer des emplois au
quotidien et qui s'adapte à tout le
monde on peut avoir des temps partiels
mais pour des personnees qui souhaitent
travailler mais garder aussi un côté euh
aide à sa famille élever ses enfants ou
au personnes qui recherchent
véritablement un nombre d'heur important
donc on est en capacité de répondre à
ses besoins et aussi de pouvoir apporter
une réponse à l'évolution de notre
société pour nos grmoun qui sont de plus
en plus soit isolés ou soit ne peuvent
pas ou n'ont pas les moyens
d'être mis en établissement pour la
retraite donc de les garder dans les
cocons familiales et c'est vraiment un
bonheur de de participer à ce projet de
vie